an off-duty connecticut police officer
accused of killing a fellow officer in a
dui crash will face a judge police say
34-year-old robert ferraro crashed a
rented rolls-royce near spring mountain
in decatur and clark county leaders are
now calling for more oversight when it
comes to those kind of exotic rental
cars we have hector mejia live in the
newsroom this morning with details on
this case hector good morning
hey there john good morning and today
clark county commissioners will discuss
a potential investigation into the local
exotic car rental industry also this
morning ferraro has a court hearing for
the two felony charges he faces metro
police say the new haven officer robert
ferraro was drunk when he lost control
of a rented rolls royce that happened on
friday the car valued at four hundred
thousand dollars rolled near decatur and
spring mountain killing fellow officer
35 year old joshua castellano they were
on vacation with a group of other
officers all from new haven clark county
commissioner michael naft says this is
highlighting a persistent issue here in
the valley involving rental car crashes
this is happening again and again and
again and something has to be done to to
make clear to people that yes you come
to las vegas for a good time we want you
to enjoy yourself we want you to spend
money but we need to make sure that the
people who are operating who are doing
business in clark county are doing it
the right way
so this morning naft says he plans to
ask county staff to look into the
existing policies and potentially
implement more oversight to make sure
every possible rule is in place things
like insurance requirements and giving
drivers some training before they can
take off in an exotic car we also talked
with a rental company that agrees more
regulation needs to happen you'll hear
from them straight ahead in the next
half hour reporting live in the newsroom
hector mejia back to you happy